welcome to this video playing swap swap
that's an IM but it's not in their
international master mullah not not sure
why it does not have it in the title
here in some a bit strange normally you
need to have it in there too to have
this this this free account as an
international master and um yeah not
sure okay um h6 is funny line sometimes
called the bull market variation named
after the Russian Grand Master Vladimir
bookmarking oh that's funny it just
retreats voluntarily okay preventing
Bishop f5 that's funny with technically
I can play it Bishop f5 because of Queen
85 check but okay not not really much
use doing that mmm interesting
what about c5 here yeah we actually
really on unexplored territory here I
don't really know if I don't not sure
about d5 I think after that 97 intending
9 p-6 might be quite good the night on
g3 is just a bit off side I think you
should take our place III probably
taking yeah but then I can maybe every a
really capture on d1 came this or I can
I can just take it okay let's let's
increase the pressure on the pawn still
it's not clear if he really wants to
capture him I can I can spoil as
castling rides and mm yeah and queen 85
is probably not so terrible as well okay
so going for an isolated green porno I
guess yeah but now I'd like to develop
the dish of course not play six many six
is not bad because he's got somebody
edge nights for an isolated Queen porn
position but still I would like to
develop the bishop but there's no a
decent way to do it now okay probably I
must do that ok question where where to
go e 7 yeah I guess
oh that's a very unconventional way to
play it with the isolated Queen pond
okay whenever I can even play you five
jump form and I really know what to make
out of it is it's positionally am I
think the dangerous move for for white
simply because um it kills the bishop
1c1 but he can play a5i in other
circumstances g6 would have been a good
reply to a form but I have played h6
already some I am I don't want to do
that gee successes f5 immediately and h6
answer came I'm going to complete my
development I know on on f5 I'm going to
play e5 yeah he cannot go d 5 after
night a 5 i'm winning the d5 pawn and ya
hear I think black should be quite solid
yeah we both spent some time here is not
a particularly good player I have fun
some games played against somewhere the
time was a substantial problem for both
of us why can go here actually let's do
that not not spend ages use this this
active moves maybe it's not leading to
much yeah not really oh yeah probably
this wasn't so greater looking like an
active continuation but it's not really
it's not really paying off g4 was
hanging this is why I went to e5 now all
this is not particularly great I mean
I'm not in trouble but
not too thrilled about this position
should I just take it 96 back maybe can
go back to f2 I don't really know what
to make make make our this position it's
got 94 possibly this is sam this is not
not too comfortable maybe i should do
this yeah I don't know I must this will
probably be decided with very little
time on the clock for both of us what I
what I tries to ya get this in
yeah this is at least a good a good porn
structure black but of course my night
on a five this is not exactly I pride
and joy of my position I take it no
first I gained this temple one rookie
seven at least yeah this is coming here
better not I want rocky seven on rock g7
I wonder maybe i can i can go here this
shouldn't be a bad end game if he takes
on f6 check the pawn structure so quite
okay for me yeah i'm attacking here I
9043 check so winning the spawn I came
time morning Jarrod's that's I think cam
helpful check 95 coming up
yeah let's let's advance the palms maybe
going to regroup at to e5 you know I'm
I'd play Bishop he ate my probably that
was great I stupid very stupid move is
going to lose on time allentown would
have been so i can play kings if I
lattice point that I think yeah I
spoiled it I saw Bishop be eight but
just too late here with without that I'm
just winning their game and want to go
to c6 may be here or a form yeah it's
just not that hotel late maybe it's even
easier not to move the pawns and first
improve here I just need to go to if I
if I manage to get to e5 with the king
at some it's much much easier yeah
that's the cleanest way here going going
right here and this this is very easy
when either get to see 5 what we five
yeah yeah it was a tricky a tricky game
we both are plate plate plate plate
slowly around here I thought after this
F 5v5 business um black should be okay
and i just have the somewhat more
harmonious position but i guess that
this is not really leading to much
computer wants to go rook c8 yeah yeah
keeping the tension always difficult
yeah this is probably just just about
equal yeah the computers always on +1
for black here bishop f6 I missed that
that's much stronger that's much
stronger attacking the rook and probably
it needs to go here and then I'm winning
a multiple multiple tempe here and at
the end the pawn that was possible that
was much better i only went I went for
this immediately yeah guide this it's
probably something that white should
hold with them with precise play but not
not easy but I'm winning this poor now
it's not that he cannot defend it I
thought he could maybe just avec he
cannot defend it really we are Ruby said
now this is going to end in a draw I
cannot believe that black shirt should
win here below clutter up t7 yeah can
you we went to the zend game which is a
bit more comfortable for black but still
probably shouldn't shouldn't be lost I
really don't understand stockfish
evaluation here giving widen advantage
this is just not realistic not against
the spawn structure it wants to play
like this 90 fire of course I'm going to
a gay guy go here Bishop d3 and then I
go into g5 what is the problem are the
king is going over here okay well so and
maybe here and no way black is I'm not
going to lose this position that's
simply not possible alright thanks for
watching